طبعا كنا احنا ساكنين في هذا البيت وكنا
احنا تقريبا 20 25 بني ادم في هذه الدار
اشتد القصف ثواني ما في ثواني بنزل فوق
للدار بتنزل وابوي وامي وعمي استشهدوا على
الفور وطبعا في ثلاثه من اخوتي في دار
ثانيه على اساس ان كان القذايف مصول
وشفناهم مرميين دفناهم في مكان لحين اننا
نقوللهم في مقابر رسميه اوع تزحلق ولا
يصير فيش ارفعوا يا
شباب ارفع يا شباب
ارفع كان القصف تحتين المدافع والطيران
واحنا دفناهم عند الجيران وثم رحلنا ما
قدرناش نجي ندفنهم في المقابر
الرسميه البلد كلها من الجرن حتى جبل
البلد رحلت كلها على الجامعات كما قالوا
في غرب غزه في هذول شهداء من تاريخ 12
1912 واليوم احنا تمكنا وقدرنا بعد الهدوء
اننا نخرج هذول
حتى نذوبهم الى المقابر
[موسيقى]
الرسميه طبعا زي ما انتم شايفين يعني بنته
اخوي سندس محمد سعد بتودع ابوها محمد سعد
وهو الاخ الاكبر لنا من شهر وهو يعني
ابوها استشهد مش قاعد توده ولا تشوفه بحسب
الاوضاع اللي كانت موجوده وكلنا رحلنا
لغرب
غزه لا انا ولا اهلي ولا ولا زوجه اختي
ولا و بنات اخوي قدروا يودعوا من اول يوم
ان يعني من 19 لحتى التاريخ اليوم اكثر من
شهر ماضل من الشهر واحنا مش عارفين نقدر
نزور او نصل هذا المكان الا بعد طرا
كبيره
راس